- [Spoken Together] Bad blood.
- A feud has been brewing
between pop starlets,
Taylor Swift and Katy Perry.
So we hit the Teen
Choice Awards red carpet
to settle once and for all,
- Who smells better, Katy
Perry or Taylor Swift?
("Poperazzi Main")
- You gotta give us a whiff.
- Oh yeah, oh he's going in for it.
- They smell the same
but yours is more strong
- Really?
- So I'm gonna go with you.
- Alright!
- Yours is a little, cotton candy.
But I think I like yours better.
(bell clangs)
- I think so too, right?
Get a good deep inhale.
- Don't tell me how to sniff okay?
- I know how to sniff.
You know what, you're a little
too sweet for my liking.
- Wow!
- So I'm gonna go with a.
(bell dings)
- Oh! Oh I like yours better.
- Yeah, right?
I'm wearing Katy Perry and you're wearing,
- Taylor Swift.
- Oh, I change my answer.
(bell dings)
- Are you, are you
Taylor? Are you a Swifty?
- [Robbie] Is that Bad Blood?
- Wait.
- Yeah, get in there. As
much as you want, really.
The best day of my life.
- It's feel like cuz
we're in August right now,
I'm liking this one.
(bell dings)
- That's what we've heard.
- This one actually smells kinda familiar.
I wonder if I wear that one?
I'm gonna go with this one.
(bell dings)
- Yeah!
- Is it Katy Perry?
- [Blonde Man] Yes it is!
- I'm wearing Katy Perry right now.
- Oh my God!
- More vanilla, like musky.
More kinda like gardenia or jasmine.
- Whoa.
- I prefer this one.
(bell dings)
- Only because it's
something that I would wear.
- Floral scents kinda make me sneeze.
- I think my first instinct was yours.
(bell dings)
- Yes!
- Which was?
- Katy Perry and he's
wearing Taylor Swift.
- Aww. I love both though, I love both.
- I do like that one.
- Yeah?
- But I think I'm partial to you.
(bell dings)
- I think so too, right?
- I'm sorry. Listen,
welcome to my entire week.
Like, I was chosen as A
and a lot of people were bummed about it.
- Give us a whiff.
- I can't really smell.
- Gonna reapply.
- That's nice.
- I got it in my eye.
- [Blonde Man] It is isn't it?
- I love them both
- I really do.
- But like decision time.
- Maybe yours.
(bell dings)
- Yes! Thank you!
- Who do you think smells better
between the two of us?
(bell dings)
- Ladies always think I smell good.
(laughter)
- We definitely gotten enough for a video.
We don't need anyone
else to smell our necks.
But we do see Victoria Justice
so we are gonna have her smell us.
- Mine's more on the neck
so you have to get
really, really in there.
- I'm gonna have to go with.
(bell dings)
- Yes!
- You didn't even think about it!
- So that settles it.
Coming in like a dark horse
and the true California girl that she is,
Katy Perry emerged victorious.
- Whatever, I'm still cuter.
- How does Flo settle a feud?
- I mean you just, get together
and just give each other a big hug
- Hash it out.
- Or hug you cuz you smell amazing.
(laughter)